The Joe Rogan Experience this is now
really big science and Pharma is moving
in very quickly what they're trying to
do is create
non-psychedelic psychedelics figure out
what sorts of chemistry changes that
doesn't give you hallucinations and
create new antidepressants that's what
they want to do with psilocybin because
doing two Journeys on a drug and then
you're done that's not good business and
what I love about what Michael pollen is
saying is that he's the one that's
really he's really hitting the drum on
this one he's saying these things work
the clinical data are showing that 65
plus success rate for what would
otherwise be intractable untreatable
suicidal depression incredible and now
the universities are behind it but
they're behind it because Laboratories
are getting funded to do it Laboratories
are getting funded do it because there's
the there are grants why are there now
grants from the federal government well
philanthropists came in early and
provided money and now the people are
starting to see that there is there are
big big potential outcomes at the level
of Pharma now the classic psychedelics
Community isn't going to like that
they're like no this is plant medicine
it's got a hundred thousand year history
or more
indigenous people Etc
Academia and Pharma don't care about
that and I'm not I'm not I'm one of
these people I don't I'm not saying
they're bad and they're good I'm saying
that it's humans again so why are
universities suddenly okay with the idea
of discussions about psyched dogs in
front of their top tier donors the
people that literally Supply the blood
to the university well because top tier
donors are now really interested in
psychedelics
so what drives every aspect of it from
the student who's pipetting in the lab
to the the highest tier of
administration in the university all the
way up to directors of NIH
it's it it's all interconnected at the
level of incentives right but the top
tier donors are clearly influenced by
the Zeitgeist and the the way people
have approached and thought about
psychedelics has radically changed
completely over the last 10 years and
Michael pollen is one of the reasons for
that because the Omnivore's Dilemma he
had established himself as a legitimate
journalist who would comb through and
parse through all the data to give you a
comprehensive understanding of what
exactly is going on and he went out and
did them or at least some of them as as
a kind of late the typical person not
yeah and didn't come out with um wearing
you know a robe right you know and or
sit in the Lotus position and he can
discuss them like a journalist right and
then having podcasts discuss it then
you're getting this these positive drug
stories out to and I don't even like
calling them drugs positive compound
stories about psychedelics that are
going out to millions and millions and
millions of people and you're hearing
about these people particularly soldiers
who are coming back of PTSD who are
having tremendous results people with
overwhelming depression people with all
sorts of problems with drug addiction
and so many different ailments that are
being helped in this way yeah absolutely
and look you deserve tremendous credit
here I know you're not one to you know
sit here and take praise from your your
guessing but I'm going to just say that
you've been talking about this for a
long time about the tremendous value of
these things not just for gaining new
perspective because I think in the 60s
and 70s it was remember it was tune in
and drop out right now we're talking
about the use of psychedelic medicine to
be able to lean into life in a healthy
way yeah that's the major difference and
you've really pioneered the discussion
around that Michael Paulin and and there
are others too I realize but it you know
at a time when it was considered really
wacky and out there now it's becoming
it's headed towards mainstream medicine
and I think it's fundamentally important
I mean I think Robin cardard Harris's
laboratory at UCSF has a paper out just
today on the use of DMT for treatment of
psychiatric illness
his laboratory has been looking at high
dose psilocybin two sessions guided
sessions
treatment of anorexia ADHD and
depression with very high success Nolan
Williams Lab at my at my University at
Stanford
psycho he's a triple board certified
psychiatrist neurologist running the
studies with veteran Solutions the group
down in Mexico of tier one operators and
other people who come back who are just
messed up their their light they're
either heading towards suicidal
depression or they're just not feeling
quite right and using abigaine DMT in in
Tandem and getting tremendously positive
results so he's doing the neuroimaging
on them so times are really changing and
you and Michael and others really
deserve our token of gratitude I've
completely revamped my stance on
psychedelics I'm still yet to do a
high-dose psilocybin journey I haven't
done that yet what was your original
stance on psychedelics I don't want to
lose my job and I'll be honest so I was
kind of a wild youth barely finished
high school and I did recreationally I
took LSD and psilocybin in high school
hung around the Wild Bunch and we were
just partying with it I didn't know what
I was doing so my view of it was it was
associated with a time in my life where
I was pretty Wayward right
um then I never touched it I drank a
little bit smoked a little bit of weed
here and there but never really liked
weed very much it just wasn't my thing
and then when I did this three sessions
with MDMA that completely transformed my
understanding of how these drugs work I
also realized and you might you probably
already know this but I was very curious
about MDMA and the reputation that puts
holes in the brain kill serotonin
neurons you know the study on MDMA that
showed neurotoxicity is was retracted
from science they actually inadvertently
injected methamphetamine into those
monkeys but you never hear about that
how do you inadvertently inject
methamphetamine I thought it was aspirin
you don't hear about that retraction you
hear that so they now have data in
humans asking what are the safety
profiles on MDMA for people that take it
every once in a while to ver to people
have taken hundreds of doses of MDMA and
there's one population of people that
you can do this on that makes it a
really good experiment those people
can't do any other drugs because then it
becomes confounded by are they doing
math are they doing coke are they
getting psilocybin what else it's not a
good experiment you want single variable
manipulation there's only one group that
you do that on and that's who they did
it on and that's Mormons so that so the
Church of Latter-day Saints has one drug
that's not on the banned substance list
and that's MDMA wow and I'm not saying
all I can't even drink coffee it makes
it even better experiment
and so I'm not saying that Mormons are
all taking MDMA but there are there is a
there is a substantial number of LDS
Latter-Day Saints I think they call
themselves now Mormons as most people
know them who have taken tons of MDMA
and they've done brain Imaging and
psychiatric profiles on them those data
say that done as long as it's not
contaminated with something else which
is a serious issue the neurotoxicity is
nil to none